more clark county school district
students are returning to buildings
tomorrow
for classes in person now this comes
after pre-kindergarten to third grade
students went back earlier this month
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
joins us live in the newsroom tonight
with more on preparations and what to
expect kristen
sasha the district anticipates about 27
thousand students in grades 6
9 and 12 starting hybrid learning
tomorrow it's a very big day following
more than a year of distance education
for secondary school students i'm so
excited to be going back
eager and enthusiastic honestly like an
answer to my prayers
macy beck welcomes taking classes in
person again at sierra vista high school
having conversations with students my
age is exciting but i also just don't
know what it's going to be like and it
is a little bit nerve-racking
what's so nerve-wracking about it going
back to normal just seems
not right in a way but at the same time
it's something that i've wanted
so bad the senior and student body
president expects an adjustment
so to ease those returning she and the
student council decorated parts of the
school
we have like four different hallways
that we deck out in the theme to
have the students get excited about
coming back all middle and high school
buildings making various preparations
before
monday that includes positioning desks
for social distancing
our custodians are phenomenal and they
actually set up our classrooms for us
billy hemberger teaches at spring valley
high school he says
the big concern starting monday the
hybrid schedule
students take two classes in person then
finish the school day remotely online
the morning courses are now an hour and
45 minutes
there's no way to prepare other other
than
for me anyway i'm just going to kind of
do it and learn as
learn as i go are there any concerns
with the new hybrid schedule i'd be
lying if i said it made sense to me
because it doesn't but for beck it beats
the alternative of continuing full-time
distance education
this is what we have to work with then
we'll work with it
the district gave students a choice of
returning to campuses
or not which means continuing full-time
distance education
they are split among three cohorts and
cohort a
is who starts tomorrow reporting live in
the newsroom kristin drummond 8 news now